el cielo nocturno brilló con un rojo
infernal mientras la lava descendía por
el mauna loa de Hawaii el mayor volcán
activo del mundo la erupción comenzó a
las 11:30 hora local del domingo
poniendo fin a 38 años de descanso pero
aunque ocurrió de forma repentina No fue
una gran sorpresa ya sabes estamos muy
retrasados estábamos muy retrasados con
la erupción del maunaloa y por eso no
sabíamos preparado el servicio geológico
de Estados Unidos asegura que la lava no
es una amenaza para los hawaianos que
viven en la Ladera inferior por ahora ya
que el flujo se limita a la cima ahora
es la ceniza volcánica tóxica la que
está causando preocupación con las
autoridades poniendo bajo aviso de caída
de ceniza a varias partes de la gran
Isla
sé que algunas aerolíneas han
o cancelado vuelos desde ilo por el
peligro de las cenizas porque no quieren
que las cenizas entren en los motores de
los aviones es una mala combinación y
luego está el peligro de los gases
volcánicos para hacer lo que llaman Rock
esta Niebla volcánica esto puede ser
malo para las vías respiratorias porque
tiene gotas de ácido
significa montaña larga cubre casi la
mitad de la isla y no es extraño verlo
entrar en erupción desde 1946 lo ha
hecho 33 veces no queremos tratar de
adivinar el comportamiento del volcán
tenemos que dejar que nos muestre lo que
va a hacer y luego informar a la gente
lo antes posible su última erupción en
1984 duró tres semanas y los flujos de
lava se detuvieron a solo 8 kilómetros
del primer pueblo